DAVE BURKE: Welcome, everyone,
to our inaugural Android
Developers Summit here at
the Computer History Museum
in Mountain View, California.
It's great to see so many
Android developers here,
from some of the biggest
names and emerging names,
all under one roof.
And I also want to say a
big welcome to everybody
who's joining us on
the livestream today.
OK.
So speaking of history,
I joined Google in 2007,
and it was a time when
computing was quite different.
So the focus, really,
of the company
was really laptops
and desktops, and it
was before mobile
had really taken off.
And Larry and Sergey,
the co-founders
of Google, to their credit
kind of foresaw how mobile
was going to change how
we interact with computers
on a daily basis.
And so they wanted to create a
strategic investment in mobile.
So we created a separate
group within Google
to focus on mobile applications.
And the goal of the group was
to take existing Google Apps
and services and bring them to
the mobile phones at the time.
Now remember this
was 2007, so it
was a pretty different world.
And in particular,
there was no Android,
and there was no iPhone.
And the devices that were
available at the time
were quite primitive.
So you had a whole
fragmentation of technologies
across different
device manufacturers.
So you would see J2ME
in one device maker.
You would see Symbian.
And then even within
Symbian, there
were two variants, UIQ and S60.
You'd have Palm OS.
You'd have Windows Mobile.
And it was brutal as an
application developer
to have to target all
of these different SDKs,
because each one would
have different capabilities
and limitations.
And what you would
invariably find
is that because
they're so different,
you would have to hire
application developers
for each technology vertical.
It was really, really tough.
But we soldiered on, and
we created a whole set
of applications and services.
So we had Waf versions
of Google Search.
We had HTML versions
We used to have radio buttons.
You had to like, tell
Google whether you were
searching for web or images.
That was before we had something
called Universal Search.
We had J2ME versions of Maps.
We had J2ME versions of
YouTube, of Gmail, et cetera.
Even within Google Maps, not
only did we have J2ME versions,
we had a Windows Mobile version.
We had a Series 60 version.
We had a UIQ version.
We had a Palm OS version.
We had a HTML version.
It was very, very tough.
And it was very, very
tough to scale, even
for a company with the
resources like Google.
So we did something
better, which
then brought us to Android.
And at the time,
when analysts would
hear about the
Android project, they
would sort of criticize it.
And they would be like, OK.
This is the last thing
the world needs is yet
another mobile operating system.
And Andy Rubin, who started
the Android project-- he
would agree.
But he would say,
what the world needs
is an open-source
mobile operating system.
And so with Android,
we also want
a platform that has the
application developer in mind.
So we spend a lot of time
worrying and thinking
about our API
design to make sure
that we have a really good
application framework.
Every year when we
do a dessert release,
we run what we call API Council.
And it's a group of core
engineers on the team.
And they review all the
prospective new APIs,
all the method names,
all the property names,
all of the sort of
styles that people
are using across the team.
And we make sure that we
have one consistent style.
So if you're writing
an application,
and you're interacting,
say, with our Camera2 APIs.
And then you're talking
to a sensor manager
to read sensor readings.
Or you're manipulating
your view hierarchy.
We want it to feel like
it's one person who had
designed those APIs for you.
Even more important
is making sure
that we have consistency
of those APIs
across different devices.
And so the way we
do that is we have
something we call a
Compatibility Definition
Document.
And it's a document describing
all of the requirements
that a compatible
device must exhibit.
And it's backed by hundreds
of thousands of tests
that we call the
Compatibility Test Suite.
And so if you're a
device maker, and you
want to make an
Android device, you
have to pass these hundreds
of thousands of tests
to be able to use
the Android brand.
And for your device to be
able to access the Play Store.
And what this does is it ensures
that you, as an application
developer, can
target applications
that work across a
variety of device makers.
And then you, as a
user, can download apps
and have certainty that the app
will run well on your device.
So CTS is an ongoing project.
We're constantly
investing in it.
In just the last
12 months, we've
added over 80,000 OpenGL
tests, for example.
And this allows us to test some
of the very latest features
in OpenGL right up to 3.1.
And it ensures that if
you're a game developer,
and you're using those
latest features in OpenGL,
we can make sure
that they're going
to work well on modern devices.
So of course, now what
this enables other people
to-- not only third parties but
even Google's first parties.
We can now use Google
Android's public APIs
to deliver very
advanced services.
Things like navigation
and Google Maps,
or VR with Cardboard.
These are features
that would have
been extremely difficult,
if not impossible,
on previous platforms.
So what's happening now?
Well effectively, we are in the
midst of a mobile revolution.
We just announced last month
over 50% of Google searches
are now happening on mobile.
And for me, having
started in 2007,
this is an incredible
number to see.
I remember we would
look at traffic graphs,
and we would
literally see mobile
was like, this little blip.
Whereas now, it takes
up half of the area.
And of course,
Android is on a tear.
We have over 1.4 billion
30-day active users
across all form factors.
And as you know, a lot of that
is also thanks to you guys,
because a platform without
applications is not a product.
And so thank you for all of
the work that you guys do.
You know, it's
kind of interesting
when you think about it.
Because over the next couple
of years, especially emerging
markets, people who
don't have phones
are going to be getting phones.
And all phones are going
to become smartphones.
It's just an amazing
transition to be a part of.
Some people actually
predicted this.
I love this quote.
This is from Nikola
Tesla in 1926.
And he talks about being
able to communicate
with each other
instantly, right?
Irrespective of distance.
He talks about being able
to see each other perfectly,
as though we were face-to-face.
And he talks about devices
being amazingly simple.
He finishes up,
and he says, a man
will be able to carry
one in his vest pocket.
I mean, this is very prescient.
I mean, he obviously
didn't anticipate
that women would like phones.
But he can't be perfect.
This was 90 years ago.
Hopefully we've moved on.
But it's pretty amazing to see.
Now of course, mobile technology
is advancing super fast.
And on the Android team, we
like to have a very fast pace.
And so if I just look, take a
little walk down memory lane.
So in 2009, we launched-- we
actually had three dessert
releases in one year.
So we did Cupcake.
We did Donut.
We did Eclair.
And even when those
three releases,
we released some pretty
profound at the time features.
So we had third-party
replaceable keyboards,
for example.
We had voice search available.
We had desktop class browsing.
Then in 2010, we did
two more releases.
We did Froyo, and
we did Gingerbread.
And we introduced
additional features,
like NFC and Wi-Fi Hotspot
and the Native Development
Kit for targeting games.
Then in the next year, we
did Honeycomb and Ice Cream
Sandwich.
So Honeycomb allowed us to
bring Android to tablets.
Ice Cream Sandwich then
introduced a more refined UI
with the Holo theme.
And also introducing
the Roboto font
for the first time, which you'll
now see everywhere on Android.
Fast forward, then we had
Jelly Bean, then we had KitKat.
Which then brings us to our two
most recent releases, Lollipop
and Marshmallow.
So with Lollipop, this
was an opportunity for us
to expand the
categories of computing
that Android could run on.
So we introduced support
for wearables, for watches,
for TV, and for
Android Auto and cars.
And then this year, we
introduced Marshmallow.
And the focus there
was to go back
to the core user experience.
And set a high bar
for what we believe
a quality experience and
polished experience on mobile
should be.
Just last year, we started
a developer preview process
and further refined
it this summer.
So with Marshmallow, we came out
with a set of preview releases
across the summer.
And even in the
first couple of days,
we had hundreds of
thousands of downloads.
And so what that means is
that hundreds of thousands
of developers can
start testing out
their applications on the
newest version of Android
before the release.
And you could also
try the new features.
So it's really
awesome, because it
means we're all working together
to have the best platform
releases and the
best quality apps
and services at
launch for our users.
OK.
So moving forward, that was
a little bit about timing.
We started to think about,
well, what else could we
do to make your lives a little
bit easier and more productive?
What is it that you spend
all your time doing?
Now Android Studio is
the official Android ID
and toolchain for Android,
directly from Google.
And it has the best set
of tools to help you build
better, more successful apps.
This year, we've made a huge
stepwise change in investment
in our tools.
And we're working on some
really great features that
are rolling out both
this year, and you'll
see over the next
coming months and years.
I'm really excited
about what we're doing.
And to help you
learn more, I'd like
to invite Steph up to the stage
to talk to you about Studio.
STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Thank you guys
so much for being here today.
Android Studio has built
tremendous momentum
since we announced it
about 2 and 1/2 years ago.
Since we announced,
we've had 103 releases
into our various channels.
That includes Canary,
Beta, and Stable.
Android Studio went G8.
It came out of Beta
just about a year ago,
and since then we've had another
five major stable releases.
The last two
focused very heavily
on quality and stability.
In the Android
Studio team, our goal
is to make the IDE delightful.
And in order to
be delightful, we
felt like it had to be not just
stable, but incredibly stable.
And that's because
as a developer,
you spend hours in
the IDE everyday.
And so, in 1.4 and 1.5, we felt
like with those significant
investments, well,
we'll continue
to make investments in stability
and quality in every release.
We have the foundation
that we wanted
to start setting our sights on
the next set of improvements,
which are really going
to focus on speed.
Now when we took a
look at the feature
set we had planned
for the next release,
we decided it was
so gigantic that we
wanted to remember the release.
So you'll see the next
version of Android Studio
will be Android Studio 2.0.
Now this is a gigantic release.
I'm going to walk you through
some of the feature set today.
When we talked to
mobile developers,
there was a few things we found.
Particularly, that there were
a number of opportunities
to make the development process
faster, smoother, and better.
In particular, when we
talk to mobile developers,
like all developers,
we found that you
spend a ton of time-- we spend
a ton of time in the code,
build, run cycle.
Right?
It's where you
spend all your time.
And now, if you think about
what it's like to code on HTML.
You make some code
edits, and then you
can refresh the page live.
Right?
So it's super fast.
Now how many of
you guys would say
it feels that way on mobile?
We felt like it
was just too slow.
It was too heavyweight.
And you had to be able
to iterate better.
So I'm going to talk
about a bunch of changes.
The first thing
you'll see coming
is, we've massively
accelerated build speeds.
So in 2.0, full build,
the first time you build,
will be 2 to 2 and 1/2
times faster than it was.
So if before, your build
was taking you a minute,
now it's going to be
about 20.25 seconds.
Now I know a lot of
you guys know too,
after you do a full
build, then of course,
you do an incremental build.
That's when you do the
second set of changes,
build a second time.
Incremental build
speeds are going
to be even faster than that.
They're going to be in
the single digit seconds.
And I'm going to come back to
that and talk about it more.
So the next thing I want to
talk about is the emulator.
In the code, build, run
cycle, in order to iterate,
you need to be able to quickly
see how the app looks as well.
Now a lot of you guys
in the community talk
to us about our emulators,
and here's what you said.
They are not fast enough.
They are not stable enough.
We listened to you guys, and
the truth was, you were right.
So we've made massive
improvements here in 2.0.
We have made major changes.
And let me just start
by talking about speed,
because I fairly feel like
it's the most important.
In 2.0, one of the
first things you'll find
is that they are
significantly faster.
We have ADB push speeds
that are five times faster
for the emulator than they
are in a physical device.
We've massively accelerated IO.
We've massively accelerated CPU.
So we're also adding SMP
support to take advantage
of host multicore architecture.
You will find overall that
the emulators are massively
faster than they were before.
We'd also say the emulators
continue to include
Google Play services.
So a ton of the developers
in the audience here today,
and worldwide, use
Google Play services
to get access to things like
AdMob, Maps, Authentication.
And those will all be
present, just as you'd expect.
Now in addition to significant
speed improvements,
we also completely
rewrote the UI.
So you'll see
major changes here.
In 2.0, you'll have
screen rotation,
screen shots, windows, zooming
of the emulator window.
You'll be able to take an
APK and drag and drop it
onto the emulator.
I will say a personal
favorite of our engineering
director and one that he
pushed really hard for.
A couple of you
guys in the audience
asked us for the ability to
grab the edge of the emulator
and pull it down and
back to resize it.
And you will also
find that in 2.0.
So that's not all.
You're going to find
you'll have the ability
to emulate GPS location.
So you can pass
in a single point.
You can pass in a set of
points, like me walking over
to the keynote today.
You can emulate calls.
You can emulate texts.
You can emulate camera.
You can emulate battery states.
So you want to see
how your app is
going to perform
when the battery is
full or really drained.
So overall, a very,
very significant
set of changes in the emulator.
Again, the reason why we
felt this was so critical
is you have to be able to
iterate in your app and fast.
And every minute that you're
sitting around-- you're
waiting for builds.
You're waiting for run speed.
That's a minute wasted.
So with 2.0, the IDE is designed
to help you stay constantly
in the flow while you're coding.
So you can iterate and try
things out on a single device.
Now one of the things
Dave talked about
is we have 1.4 billion
active users on Android.
And so that means there's also
a ton of devices out there.
And that was another
reason why we felt
the emulator was so important.
So you could test not
just on the device
that you have next to you, but
across a multitude of devices.
One of the things that
we hear from developers
everywhere is that the
emulator is very important,
but physical devices
are important as well.
And that's why we
have decided to have
world-class support for both.
So let me talk about
some more changes.
Android also has a
very important set
of developers doing what I would
call graphics-intensive apps.
So this would be things
like Maps, Games, video,
things of this nature.
We do a lot of it
at Google as well.
And so, that's why
in 2.0, we're also
including a very early
preview of our new GPU
profiler and debugger.
So one of the big problems with
graphics-intensive development
is you'll see a scene,
and you get a problem.
And you're not really sure
exactly what caused it.
So one of the things you'll find
in the GPU Profiler is you're
able to record and replay the
entire stream, frame by frame.
So you can understand
and debug in the GL code.
So now graphics developers
can save countless hours
when debugging graphics
rendering problems.
Another thing I want to talk
about is core IDE improvements.
Android is built
on top of IntelliJ.
And being built on
top of IntelliJ means,
as fast as Android Studio
itself has been innovating,
IntelliJ's own incredibly rapid
pace propels us even faster
all the time.
Now IntelliJ released
their newest version,
15, just about three weeks ago.
And Android Studio 2.0 already
fully integrates IntelliJ 15.
You'll see that in
the Canary builds.
So there's a ton that
comes with IntelliJ 15.
One of the features I thought
I would touch on in particular,
because we care about
it so much, is testing.
Another thing we hear
a lot from developers
is how critical it is
to be able to build
high-quality apps by default.
IntelliJ includes a wide range
of new features for testing,
including a Test
Runner tool window.
It's got inline statistics
and test result history.
You can right-click and
then execute a test.
And we've also added
on that, in Studio
itself with a couple of key
asks from the community.
One of the things
you guys asked us for
is to be able to run
all test types together.
As you guys know,
in Android Studio
you can have two test types,
unit tests and Android tests.
And now, you can have both of
those active at the same time.
One of the things
that means too,
is you can now refactor
seamlessly across your code.
So you can make a change
in app code, refactor it.
It will go across
all test types.
All right.
So I have talked so
far about coding.
Talked about building,
and talked about IntelliJ,
and everything that
we got from them.
We've talked about
debugging, testing.
I want to touch
on one final area,
and that's deployment and
making your app discoverable.
One of the things
that we did in 2.0
was work very closely with
the Google Search team.
They have a wonderful
feature called deep linking,
which allows you to expose
your app so that it can
be found in the Google search.
But one of the key
questions is, OK.
How do I get this
set up in my app?
So we've added support for
this in Android Studio 2.0.
The first thing you'll
find is something
called Intention Actions.
So what this means is you
can go into Android Studio.
And as you're in
your code, it will
suggest to you inline where you
need to put code and actually
expand and show you
how to configure it.
Now the second thing we
have is static analysis.
So I'm sure, you know, none of
you guys in the audience, much
like Dave Burke, have
ever made coding mistakes.
But I will be honest and
say, I make them frequently.
So the static analysis
we have in 2.0
will check and make sure that
your deep links are configured
correctly.
The third thing we've
added is real-time testing
so that you can actually
see whether Google can index
and render the app
pages correctly.
So with Android
Studio 2.0, we know
we still have a couple
of users out there who
are using our Eclipse tools.
And we wanted to
say to you, there
is really no better
time than now
to switch to Android Studio.
It is a massive
speed improvement,
and we believe it
will significantly
accelerate your development.
A couple other things we'd say.
Android Studio remains
open-source, free to all.
And there's just one more thing
we had wanted to talk about
while we were here.
With development,
I feel like one
of the most amazing feelings
is when you're in the flow.
You're relaxed.
You're coding.
There's this timelessness where
you're incredibly productive.
And so it was in the interest
of enabling developers
to code like that,
that we created
a new feature that is called
Android Studio Instant Run.
Instant Run is designed so
that you can make changes
in code or resources,
and they'll
update into your live app
near, more or less, instantly.
So as you're coding, you
can press the Run button,
and your changes will deploy
live into the running app.
And you're going to find
this is going to take you,
on an average Android app,
about one to two seconds.
Now we are still expanding
the set of code changes
that will be covered
in Instant Run.
You will find, for those of you
who watch the Canaries closely,
and I know that's a lot
of people in this room,
it'll expand very rapidly
over the coming weeks.
But there's a few things
that we felt like were
important from the beginning.
We know you guys are
using a ton of emulators.
You're using a ton of devices.
And people out there
are running phones
with a lot of different
versions of Android.
So I'll say a couple things
about it from the outset.
First, Instant Run will work on
virtually every emulator in use
today.
Second, Instant Run
will work on virtually
every current physical device.
And third, it will work
on virtually every version
of Android that has
significant use today.
That is all the way back to Ice
Cream Sandwich or API Level 15.
The web really became
successful in the early days
because you could edit HTML.
You could see how it looked
on a browser right away.
And now, our goal is to bring
a similar lightweight feel
to mobile development.
We're incredibly grateful
for all the feedback
from our community that's
led us in this direction.
We were talking about
the future beforehand,
and we were talking
about Dave Burke.
I think he's giving you
a cool overview of what
the early days, the
hard days looked
like for Android development.
And we thought it
would be really
neat to have Dave Burke come
back up on stage and demo
for you Android
Studio 2.0 and Instant
Run to get a feel for
the new, lightweight way
to do mobile development.
So with that, I'd like to
welcome Dave Burke back
to the stage.
DAVE BURKE: All right.
So we'll switch to the
developer machine here.
OK.
Cool.
So preview version of
the ID, live coding.
What could possibly go wrong?
All right.
So what I've got here
is a video shield.
This is a live tablet.
Live physical tablet.
We have it projecting a picture
in picture on top of here.
I have the latest version
of Android Studio in 2.0.
I have an app that Romain
Guy and Matthew [INAUDIBLE]
helped me create.
It's a chess game.
It's got some cool
physically-based lighting.
And what I want to do is
show you a couple of things.
I want to show you
changing resources.
change in code.
So if I change a resource
like an XML layout,
what we're going to do--
we call that a warm swap.
We're going to upload
the new resources.
We're going to invalidate
the frame caches,
and then we'll
restart the activity.
But before I do that, let
me just get the app running.
So I'm going to go Control-R.
So the IDE is building
the app, compiling it.
It's ADB installing it.
The package manager
is doing its thing.
Its dexopting.
And now it's going
to run the app.
So it takes a bit of time.
Previously in an old
world, every time
you made a code change, you
had to go through that process.
So here's how it looks
with Android Studio 2.0.
So let's say I want to change
the background of the settings
screen.
So I go to my XML layout.
And I want to add a background.
So I've got a background
bitmap that I want to add here.
So I can just go
android:background, like so.
If I can type.
Like that.
And then, I have
a drawable set up.
This is a preview
of Android Studio.
All right.
So we're all good.
OK.
So what's cool here
is that to run it,
I just go Control-R. It
will send up the new-- OK.
It's going to restart
because I busted it.
So we'll change
this in a second.
Let me let this
start again here.
OK.
So you can see.
Normally what would
happen there is
that would just restart the
activity, which would not
cause a reinstall.
So it's the same
thing that happens
when you rotate the screen.
I'll change another resource.
This time I won't mess it up,
so you can actually see it work.
So there's a, you can see
it says "New button" there.
I can change the string.
And I can say, "New
game," like this.
Dot dot dot, Control-R. OK.
You know what, I'm
going to reset this.
Hold on.
One of the advantages of
a livestream, by the way,
is you can edit it after the
fact and remove the thing.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to uninstall this app.
OK.
So I'm showing you what
real development looks like.
This is good.
So I'll leave "New game" there.
Right?
And I'll go back here, and I
will remove this line here.
Like that.
And then we'll do a
normal building compile.
So it's going to
build and compile.
And it's going to install it.
It'll take a couple of seconds.
OK.
Now it's running.
So I add this line back in here.
Like so.
And then I just do my
Control-R. And what it'll do
is, it'll just
restart the activity.
So you'll see a little flicker,
and it just restarts like that.
OK.
Thank you.
Now what's more interesting--
so we call that a warm swap.
Right?
So it's the same thing
as rotating the screen.
Much more interesting
is when you want
to do what we call a hot swap.
And the way this works is that
we're instrumenting the code.
And every time you
compile, we run an analyzer
and see if we could hot
swap the code at run time.
And so we can change
method implementations
of a class on the fly.
So if I go into the
chess activity up here,
and so we have this
on draw frame call.
So this is getting
called 60 times
a second to update the screen.
Now if I change something like,
let's change these values here.
And I change this value here.
So what this will do is it will
turn the chessboard into a 3D
animated scene.
So I just go Control-R. The
code dynamically changes,
and then boom.
Instantly, it just
updates like that.
So it turns out that I work in
a company full of overachievers
who are very good at chess.
And I needed an advantage.
So what I'm going to do is
try to find an advantage.
Now the first thing,
anybody who watches
rugby has ever seen the All
Blacks play from New Zealand
will know.
The trick to winning is to
intimidate your opponent.
So what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to go and try to make
my chess pieces larger.
So I get the vertex
mesh for my piece.
My pieces are going to
be Player 1, I suppose.
So do that.
Boom.
And then what I'll do is I'll
iterate over each of my pieces,
like this.
So P1 size, get all the
chess pieces, like that.
And then what we'll do is we'll
get each of my pieces, one
by one, the index i.
And then I have a convenience
method to set the scale.
And then I'll set
that to, I don't know,
1.75 seems like a good
intimidation factor.
Like that.
And then Control-R, boom.
And the gold pieces
jump up like that.
So also to get an
extra advantage,
I think I'll make my
opponents a little smaller.
So I can just go,
Command-D, like this.
By the way, if you have
not started using Studio,
the autocomplete in this
IDE is kind of amazing.
Like, watch this.
Boom, boom.
It's super fast.
So let's make my opponents 0.75.
And of course, that's Player 2.
Control-R, boom.
And all the black
guys get small.
All right.
Now it turns out, he's a
squirrely little opponent.
Won't be easily intimidated.
I need to have a more
meaningful material advantage.
So what I'm going to do
is get my pieces again.
So I'm Player 1.
And then I'm going to
set-- oops, a little typo.
So get the pieces, so i.
And then what I'm going
to do is set the mesh.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to get the vertex mesh
for some more powerful pieces.
So I guess, getMesh, and
then queen would be good.
And then I like the gold colors,
so we'll stick with that.
And then, hit semicolon there,
and then Control-R. Boom.
I am now going to win this game.
All right.
So that's Instant Run.
It's pretty awesome.
And that's available
in the Canary channel
this morning, so
you can try it out.
It's a preview build.
OK.
So we have a packed
set of days here
at the Computer History Museum.
If you're on the
livestream, we've
got 15 more hours of content.
On day one, we're going to
focus on framework skills.
Again, what's amazing here is
we have the Android engineering
team who built
these features here.
So you can learn so much
from just talking to them.
They're a friendly
bunch, mostly.
Especially after lunch, when
they've had their lunch--
b before lunch, not so much.
Day two, we're going to focus
on tooling and performance.
We're going to talk about
some of the newer features
that we've added,
like data binding.
We'll talk about some of the
Android testing frameworks.
The new Doze feature
and much more.
We also have the
self-paced tutorials
outside on lots of
Android topics, everything
from performance to writing
watch faces for Android Wear.
We'll also make those available
to people online later today,
so you can try them at home.
So with that, I just
want to say thank you
so much for your time, and
enjoy the rest of the summit.